white house senior adviser cedric
richmond laying out what the biden
administration is really focused on
but how do racial-based reparations make
life better for middle-class americans
what about the lives of cedric
richmond's former constituents in
louisiana's second congressional
district
joining me now is louisiana
congressional candidate claston bernard
he's running for richmond's old seat
claston
you say that reparations are a gimmick
explain well you know today
there are people who went through um a
lot
you know um he's talking about probably
college will the 90 year old
go to college with someone who you know
the reality is we've had reparations
since 1960s i think over 226 billion
dollars have been spent on government
programs to help minorities
and where's that money where are we
today
you know we keep talking about um
reparation
as if the people who were responsible
for what happened
200 years ago are still alive biblically
speaking it says
the people who commit the crime are the
ones who are actually responsible
you should not hold the children of
those people responsible for the sins of
their parents
you know we have to move away from this
slavery was ugly
jim crow was nasty but the reality
didn't break black america
government program broke black america
giving them money
and right now i think they know they're
in trouble the person in the white house
is insensitive to blacks look at his
crime bill look at what he has done
they're looking for some more gimmickry
another another character dangle to the
people
and you know because a piece of new york
magazine
i'm sorry a piece of new york magazine
today noted that a big
problem facing the democrat party was
that as
white liberals increasingly define the
party's image and messaging
that's going to turn off non-white
conservative democrats
hillary clinton voters with conservative
views on crime policing and public
safety
were far more likely to switch to trump
well claston tonight the house of
representatives passed a bill
that will strip hundreds of millions of
dollars from police departments across
the country
now who benefits from taking money away
from policing to keep neighborhoods safe
majority blacks and this is a problem
it's always virtue signaling they're
always looking out for their status quo
and it sounds good
but they need to talk to the black
mothers who are crying for their you
know their last
the lost loved ones you know they need
to talk to the people who have been you
know
mowed down in the street we have a
problem with all this
this stuff that they're doing and it's
not helping black people you know
i just say this government just need to
leave black americans alone
give them the opportunity to stand on
their own two feet you know for over 200
years
people like douglas been saying that you
know
just level the playing field and leave
us alone
and allow us to find out who we are as a
people
and i think wouldn't be in a lot better
position defunding the police
hurt minority communities and the the
reality is
probably only three percent of um people
in the in the minority community commit
most of the crime
you know so you are endangering go ahead
class and we're going to have you back
um i'm fascinated by this race i think
you're going to do a great job
you're going to surprise a lot of people
thank you so much